heute leitet clemente den anwohner
doch welche rolle spielt dieser ort beim
das militär diese anlage unter
erinnert daran wie real die bedrohung
die meisten gegnerischen schiffe haben
dem erfolgreichen angriff 1941 weiter
überzeugt seine bürger davon was die
geschütztes land soll die insel ans
liegt im fruchtbaren fatal einer oase in
kanonen schützen die bucht von delaware
bewohner fühlten sich widerstandslos
1939 bis 1944 besetzt erst das
dorf selbst bleibt von den wassermassen
spanien ist nun schon lange eine stabile
albaniens angst vor einer invasion geht
ort für franco szene man entschloss sich
der erfolge beschließt das japanische
der anderen seite der bucht
ist eine sehr friedliche gegend
ostblockstaaten die ohnehin ein
fruchtbaren acker von asco dessen
entwicklung steht der größte einsatz
eine mammutaufgabe die albanien nur mit
sind die usa noch nicht in den krieg
18 schiffe sinken am eingang zur bucht
viele der bauten vergessen und verlassen
pilger gäste und des fruchtbaren am
glaube wenige leute wissen wie mächtig
sehen sie sich in den bunkern umschauen
eisernen vorhang passiert der albanien
im tal ein wasserreservoir anzulegen und
1945 legt das deutsche u-boot
verwittern zwischen den dünen
ordnet er den bau unzähliger bunker an
zwar mit schwerem geschütz ausgerüstet
gibt keine aufzeichnungen irgendwelcher
ersetzen die japaner torpedos ein um
hat bereits in europa für verwüstung
werden mittlerweile umfunktioniert
hergestellt wurde ist bis heute nicht
die sowjets dann die chinesin roger hat
gebäude so weit das auge reicht heute
setzen wir alles daran dass sich dieser
der massenhafte bunkerbau war das
wollte nur noch schatten ihrer selbst
der staat im südosten europas ist
laufe von fünf monaten haben die usa 600
die zeit miterlebt ich bin hier geboren
rogers großes vorbild war josef stalin
der leitung von gary moore will die
befestigungsanlage war gerade fertig da
davon ganz new york city niederzubrennen
apokalyptische landschaft im herzen
das land unter der herrschaft francos
dass etwas im gange war sie hätten die
fabriken arbeiten immer schneller sie
mit fort myers den nazis die stirn
testgelände kashima die ruhige und
damals als die beste waffe der welt eine
vor angriffen geschützt werden diese
nazis hat die ostküste schwer getroffen
fokus auf toppilot technologie war ein
beschert hat wird ihm nun zum verhängnis
hier ehrenamtlich führungen an schon als
den pyrenäen als einer von vielen
stand in verbindung mit dem angriff auf
und habe die ersten zehn jahre meines
durch die nazis auch in dieser gegend
verband von asco er will den menschen
strengster geheimhaltung gebaut das
angriff auf die usa im pearl harbor
jeder wasserfall beginnt mit einem
verschont die bewohner denken zunächst
zwischen den tönen der atlantikküste
nachbarstaaten italien griechenland und
hier wie ein puzzle zu bunkern
tausende amerikaner das leben kosten
nordosten spaniens ist vor stellenweise
erlaubt wie sie galten als politisches
großbritannien in die 42 war die anlage
spanischen bürgerkrieg mit dem zweiten
steigt und die anbauflächen schrumpfen
bewaldete hügel schöne buchten der
helfen sollten waren gegen die u boote
kurz bevor ein angriff auf die us navy
es gab häuser mit balkons eine
jasser talsperre
bestand ein krieg damals aus riesigen
sekunden eine panzerbrechende kanada
militär die testanlage auszuweiten auf
festland anschließen und platz für
vergangener zeit einst mühsam erschaffen
angespanntes verhältnis zu albanien
von einer wunderschönen bergkulisse
berühmt für ihre wunderschönen strände
mao zedong zwei jahre später kündigt das
ihrem schicksal proteste waren nicht
flugzeugen ausgewählt sie haben ihn
landleben die dorfbewohner bis mitte des
dem was sie anbieten
zurück auf den zweiten weltkrieg von
demokratie
sie mit torpedos versenkt von schiffen u
ganz geklärt doch tatsumi ist überzeugt
sozialistische regierung endgültig ab
frankreichs 1940 stand großbritannien
tests
isoliert aus angst vor einer invasion
japan in der ersten hälfte des
japan den krieg im pazifik aus japans
von delaware in ein riesiges minenfeld
doch einem angriff aus den tiefen der
finden sie vereinzelt hinweise darauf
krieg niemals wiederholt dieser ort soll
einst vom westen isolierte der
eingetreten
gesorgt
musste dafür den fluss staunen der dort
die leute könnten es also tatsächlich
unterstützung von außen bewältigen kann
der diktator will spanien von grund auf
einer ansonsten trockenen region
ergebnis von verfolgungswahn dem
bieten können für viele militärexperten
explosionen und sahen den feuerschein am
lebens hier verbracht
albaniens deutet darauf hin dass das
kriegs bauten für die nachwelt erhalten
weltkrieg ging der wiederaufbau los sie
zusammengesetzt
neue gebiete zu erobern
wie alles an diesem ort zeigen auch sie
personen
schiffe verloren mehr als 5000
gemüse obst oder dass sich
pearl harbor
zwischenstopps auf dem 800 km langen
nutzlos
intelligenter schafft viele
von delaware direkt vor ort miles
massive anlage heißt batterie haring
einmal regen ging also auf die
der bucht von covert anna im südwesten
produzieren bunker für das ganze land
verbrechen der leute hier waren nicht
steht dort ein von menschen geschaffenes
es kommt immer weniger ernten
doch sie senden versorgungsschiffe den
gleicht diese gesamte gegend einer
die 74 meter hohe staumauer erschafft
zwei jahre nach dem bau wird der krieg
haben sorgt die neue allianz für unmut
die leute picknicken surfen verbringen
jugoslawien ebenso wie die atommächte
sie wirken deplatziert in dieser schönen
wasserstelle eine hübsche kirche
recht trocken aber hier gab es genug
betreten des strandes war verboten
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts war
einst war in der provinz saragossa im
ihr land zurückgeben
soll das brennt es die
sie konnten dort weiter leben das wasser
kind hat ihn der ort fasziniert
die albaner alt einzige zu stalin
einzigen tropfen
weitere gebäude schaffen
niederlage haben die japaner nie in
der delaware river ist kein besonders
übersät von seltsamen pilzförmigen
es sich mit allen großen geldgebern
es gibt keine größeren dörfer keinen
die kriegsmarine bezeichnete diese
abgeschiedene lage bietet der
alte rostige ketten hängen von schienen
die amerikaner waren aufgeboten nicht
verwandelt 500 semin die am meeresboden
zurück bleiben hunderttausende bunker
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts zufrieden und
doch woran haben die menschen hier
ideale ort für einen bürgerbus
wer dahinter steckte
hindurch fließt 1960 eröffnet franco die
hitler hat oft davon gesprochen die
extra für seichtere gewässer modifiziert
kleinen kuppeln
liegen die nazis alleine da die
das herzstück des arsenals verbirgt sich
nachthimmel
land die handelsbeziehungen zu albanien
booten oder flugzeugen aus angesichts
davon dass die anlage eine wichtige
die amerikaner schienen paranoid wer
gedanken dass der feind überall und
schaffen ihr dorf wieder aufzubauen in
wir versuchen sie als reiseziele zu
niemand durfte davon erfahren was sie
see hat es nichts entgegenzusetzen im
auf
heimatforscher und fremdenführer
feindlichen schiffen oder stellungen auf
geisterstadt
entwickelt werden sie zum teil auch auf
marineexperten sagten beide waffen immer
am nächsten morgen spürten die bellen öl
weg entlang gepilgert displays viele von
jakobsweg millionen menschen sind diesen
geschmolzener schnee auf den bergen und
verscherzt
ökologisches desaster
voraus an land feuergefechte liefern
amerikanische seeleute sind umgekommen
die menschen dazu anregen über die
hier lagen 1 maschinen man sieht immer
land schlimmes durchgemacht hat riesige
wenn ich ein neues haus bauen werden
eines tages sollen sie zurückkehren
im dezember 1941 erklärt hitler den usa
wehrmacht den balkanstaat
betracht gezogen
lustig genug um sich zu wehren sie haben
großen hafen es sind wenige boote
aufs meer
kapituliert der krieg an der ostküste
nordosten spaniens steht ein verlassenes
wollten diesen teil spaniens komplett
japanischen kriegsmarine beste
einfach einen netten tag am strand
gegend in der scheinbar nie ein krieg
reformieren in den 50er jahren nach dem
zu ende
andere waren einst leuchtende beispiele
wasser dies war ein attraktiver ort
japans ragen merkwürdige bauten empor es
den rauch und lärm dort können sie sich
delaware river hinab über den atlantik
bekannter schifffahrtsweg aber er führt
darauf hin dass an der ostküste der
ihre anordnung scheint völlig beliebt
usa und sowjetunion eine bedrohung
ersten monate der atlantik schlacht als
dem katar china testgelände proben die
bauten überall sind diese merkwürdigen
man sieht wo die leute gelebt gearbeitet
gehalten auch nach seinem tod nachdem er
es ist ein schwerer schlag für die
elterncoaching ist hier aufgewachsen
jederzeit zuschlagen könnte rogers plan
gut versorgt pross eloise clemente hat
wahrscheinlich war alles umsonst
einen der größten stauseen der pyrenäen
gearbeitet und welche rolle spielte es
sie wollten massenhaft neue torpedos
damit wollten sie den großen überfall
die überall im land verrotten einige
amerikaner haben versucht die briten
us-küste mit langstreckenraketen
vorbereitet sie dachten die nazis kommen
an der decke
diese im wasser liegen der ruine zeigt
funktion hatte
verankert waren sollten deutsche u-boote
hauptpunkten lässt roger für sich selbst
haring war eine von vier geschützt
vergangenheit nachzudenken heute sind
etablieren und bislang klappt das ganz
noch an kriegsschiff
dem festland wie in dieser einrichtung
roger hat ein gefährliches bündnis
man lebte in ständiger angst vor einem
in der aus 100.000 tonnen beton erbauten
und trümmer an
hier sehen ist amerikas erste zentrale
sommerliche regenfälle sorgen für
unterwegs
ich bin hier geboren und aufgewachsen
albanien war in einer ähnlichen
sollte die küste von delaware oder wie
ihnen haben in ascot eine pause
übrig gebliebenen ländereien haben nicht
modernisieren
voraussetzungen für geheime waffentests
vereinigten staaten einst schweres
doch dieser beschaulicher ort hat eine
der ort erinnert an dystopien wie mad
zu einem wichtigen hafen in philadelphia
stattgefunden hat
gemacht was man ihnen gesagt hat das
glückliche zeit
über den atlantik an der deutschen vater
anzugreifen und er hatte die überzogene
andere menschen auch häuser bauen und
ist zu ende
bergdorf hier haben mal menschen gewohnt
nach großbritannien nach der niederlage
kaum vorstellen die metall und beton
noch die vertiefungen sie haben die
jahren waren diese ruinen voller leben
eine katastrophe der u boot angriff der
us-amerikaner und er lässt sich nicht
schornsteine fabriken gebäude in
festlands und einer reihe ehemals
und sorgt dafür dass fast 2500 hektar
offenbar mussten sie etwas die schweres
warum sollte man wegziehen
auf pearl harbor in hawaii starten nach
als kind hat er zwischen den bauwerken
das dorf profitiert von seiner günstigen
und gebetet haben aber wo sind sie
gleichzeitig haben sie den wohnungsbau
mit einer schiffsflotte über die offene
produzieren dafür haben sie hier eine
dabei hatten andere technologien sie
unter den straßen der hauptstadt tirana
gut
darstellen
situation wie nordkorea heute innerhalb
für innere sicherheit dies ist vom 1
stellungen mit drehscheiben für 15 cm
japaner mehrmals den abschuss von
die aufstrebende spanische wirtschaft
für technologischen fortschritt und
jersey angreifen doch genau das
in ungnade gefallen war
daran hindern den delaware river
reichlich fließendes wasser der ideale
was noch geplant war torpedos galten
eingelegt um irgendwelche dank der
vorbei mit waren versorgen
geschütz zum einsatz kam ein dunkler
den krieg und schickt fünf hochmoderne
bei der attacke
geschmiedet
vor wem hatten sie angst wie er sollte
sogenannten batterie
angriff
als kind habe ich hier gerne gespielt
gereicht um alle zu ernähren
wer auch immer diese gebäude gebaut hat
see stattdessen drängen sie still und
torpedos auf schienen wagen her gebracht
das dorf wird zu neuem leben erwachen
düstere vergangenheit
deutscher inselgruppen im pazifik
bis und die restliche infrastruktur
die dorfgemeinschaft hat fest
doch in wahrheit haben hier tausende
hinaufzufahren
max oder blade runner was ist hinter dem
plötzlich taucht zwischen den dünen und
transportieren einzelne kanonen
torpedos des typs
die niederlagen und demütigungen im
vorstellungen er könnte eines tages mit
roger war kommunist durch und durch also
errichten
kanone die kanonen fordern etwa alle 15
ich erinnere mich an die übungen die uns
längst überholt
wird sie menschen hatten hier einen
neue fabrik gebaut die größte ihrer art
lage
verschiedenen stadien der verwitterung
im august 1945 werfen die usa
passierte tatsächlich
lange geheim halten die anwohner wussten
gespielt
brauchte wasser für alles möglich
weil irgendwann touristen in den bunkern
hoffnung stille zeugen von
massiv vernachlässigt alles geld floss
flussaufwärts liegen eine marinewerft
durch diesen kanal haben sie
albaniens einziger verbündeter china
land überflutet werden darunter die
übernommen um ihr reich zu beschützen
die ärzte die steingebäude sind
langstrecken u-boote richtung
wir dachten die nazis würden irgendwann
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg kamen die
zusammengehalten
es ist spitze diese dinger stehen in
mit hilfe eines langen steaks nahe fort
torpedos brauchen luft um ihren
europas war es vollkommen isoliert
die amerikanische ostküste überfallen
weil alles so dicht bewachsen und
leise bis zur amerikanischen küste vor
sie waren überall wir haben sie als
wollte so wenig zeugen wie möglich haben
91 dieser torpedo war zum abwurf aus
seinen drucken die usa besetzen
im zweiten weltkrieg ist die anlage auf
menschen ihr leben verloren alles deutet
nach und nach wurde den dorfbewohnern
busch kiefern etwas auf was dort
garten eden gefunden nur leider wollte
zweiten weltkrieg hatten große
im ganzen land
auf den ernstfall vorbereiten sollten
offensichtlich wasser geleitet
für den ackerbau als trinkwasser für die
atlantikküste hitlers unterwasser flotte
sowie waffenlager und raffinerien für
versorgt das land mit ressourcen
erfindungsreichtum
sowjets mit ihren booten
dieser teil spaniens ist allgemein sehr
urlaub machen bekommt die diktatur ihre
hat er sich an die nation gewandt die in
treibstoff zu verbrennen
im horizont auftauchen und die ostküste
überreste eines einst wohlhabenden
die amerikaner platzieren die fast 3000
brauchten die japaner eine große
furchtbar verwittert sie werden nur noch
dort drüben stand wahrscheinlich ein
überwuchert war
dies hier ist eine völlig andere art von
auswirkungen darauf wie sich albanien
jedem dorf auf jedem feld sie sind in
miles holen die amerikaner schließlich
dieser gang verläuft quer durch den
von den hügeln und bergen haben sie
überhaupt nicht hinpasst
in das buch ab
die amerikaner schienen paranoid wer
atombomben auf hiroshima und das von
wenn hitler ist geschafft hätte die
klar dass ihre existenzgrundlage im
dann ist das geheimen gearbeitet etwas
unternehmergeist und tatendrang
jemand anders ihn auch
dem höhepunkt ihrer produktivität
die erwachsenen mussten in der
sie haben über 500 riesige gebäude
spielgeräte benutzt doch sie haben einen
seinen augen den kommunismus in reinform
hochseeflotte und immer größere und
rogers bewunderung für stalin geht so
im krieg gab es unglaubliche technische
anfang des vorigen jahrhunderts haben
nach rogers tod im jahr 1985 hält das
angriffen doch sie haben ihn zu belastet
daneben ist ein becken für nutzwasser
von halb verrotteten ersten gestürzt
in diesem raum wurde komprimierte luft
die strategie der japaner war die
städte für die fabriken
kran damit haben sie die torpedos in
dorfes verlassen an einem berghang
nach dem krieg entwickelt hat
trocken aber genau hier haben sie das
und erst am ende des kalten krieges 1991
gerechte strafe für
hoch oktan iken flugzeugtreibstoff
verarbeitet werden sie auf diesem
zum gegenschlag aus sie haben die bucht
niemand wusste was in diesen gebäuden
das war eine bedrohung wir waren darauf
bunker ein unterirdisches monster mit
der ganzen gegend verstreut
riesigen bunker
versorgungslinien abzuschneiden wäre der
einen fantastischen ausblick aufs meer
kilo schweren ihnen an der tiefsten
stausee versunken war
nachbarschaft chlor vergießen und nachts
ausgefeiltere marinestützpunkte
verkörperte china bei den anderen
und auch jenseits der grenze zeichnen
ernsten hintergrund
sollte die küsten von delaware oder new
bis zu 260 menschen hier gelehrt
weit dass er sich nach dessen tod 1953
sie sind eindeutig militärischen
es ist die geschichte david gegen
errichtet inklusive der infrastruktur
gefährliches diese gebäude erzählen
drei bis fünf metern tiefe abgesetzt auf
hier nur 30 kilometer entfernten
fabrikgelände in elba sahen eingerahmt
wenn man den schienen an der decke folgt
amerikaner in den offenen pazifik zu
fortschritte in diesem gebäude haben sie
früher geschehen
vorbereitet dass die nazis am horizont
glück wasser aus den pyrenäen zu
stelle der wucht
in die torpedos geleitet
hier drüben standen wahrscheinlich
sieg in reichweite gewesen schwere
alle lichter ausmachen
albanien wäre der weitere zur eu ein
es gibt kaum hinweise darauf warum die
das war für die bewohner wie eine oase
und das musste nun mal irgendwo
fünf stockwerken und 106 zimmer
jersey angreifen
der kampf um die unabhängigkeit während
der krieg ist ihnen schon über 70 jahre
wir nennen sie die pilz bunker
nagasaki japan kapituliert und das
geschichten heute weiß man dieser ort
dort hoffen
es kamen nicht auf herkömmlichen schiff
die ein komplex von dieser größe braucht
ein wichtiger akteur ist küste diese
locken und ihre kampfschiffe und
sich probleme ab eine wende im
ursprungs man sieht über rechte von
goliath nur ohne happy end
schließt das militär ford miles
ein zwei kilometer entferntes ziel
an einer steuerung mit hochmoderner so
von der sowjetunion und dem neuen
gelangt man zu diesem monströsen
bekommen
albaner wissen dass der kommunismus
manche liegen an berghängen andere an
doch der angriff kommt tatsächlich
das zeigt ihnen wofür dieser ort gedacht
der stausee hat uns auch fruchtbarsten
der ort nimmt einen wichtigen platz in
dies war der wichtigste teil der
herkommen
toller schritt sie ist der große bruder
flugzeugträger mit torpedos abzuschießen
aufbereitungsanlagen was hier
in dieser ansonsten trockenen gegend
der stimmrechte 5 120 meter weit bis ins
gerichtet und abgefeuert
bewohner ihr dorf verließen
des krieges wird von britischen und
seit hunderttausenden von jahren ist
geschäfts
her aber er hatte überall in catania
eine moderne industrie kann es sich
nah technologie gearbeitet
familien wurden gezwungen sich an
der aufbau der gebäude liefert hinweise
gescheitert ist
hunderttausende von ihnen sind im ganzen
die usa bauen eine anlage die die
verhältnis zwischen den usa und china
gelände wird für immer stillgelegt heute
hier war platz für roger hochrangige
machthaber nikita chruschtschow abwendet
hinter mir war voller tank schütteln
der küste mit blick aufs meer
amerikanischen geheimdiensten
vorbereitungen nach jahren der
fruchtbares ackerland gibt es nur in der
können die amerikaner ihn abwehren
der geschichte japans sein
von denen wir geträumt haben es ist wie
felder überflutet die familien hat nicht
war es ist eine sehr abgelegene gegend
militäraktionen zu beteiligen
doch jemand mit viel macht hatte andere
land errichtet worden
nicht leisten auf reden zu warten esco
spuren hinterlassen murat sumi bietet
unterstützt und enver hoxha kommt an die
wie sieht eine evakuierung aus der die
tiefe gewässer und davor erstreckte sich
sorgt bei roger für empörung
heute ist die anlage ein museum sie
dieses tal immer gut mit wasser versorgt
darauf welchen zweck sie einst hatten
des hungerstreiks von studenten dann
sie sind überall und damit meine ich
nach ende des ersten weltkriegs dreht
schnellen kriegsschiffe der nazis
tal ebene doch überreste alter
vorwiegend in küstenregionen weil man
nach hause zurückzukehren
kommunistische politiker und die
das minenfeld riesige säule zwischen der
die gesamte infrastruktur ist für das
mehr genug zum leben da haben sie ihre
pläne wo
wirksam bekämpfen soll hohe
machen auch die beobachtungstürme sehen
dieses gebäude war eine testanlage für
proteste in den straßen die menschen
menschen offenbar genug zeit hatten ihre
wenn der feind diese verkehrswege
der falle eines biologischen angriff
komplette militärische führungsriege
überall die
sich hier alles darum japans
macht aber er ist ein eiserner kommunist
chruschtschow wollte die schweren
ihnen in einer japanischen bucht sie
del und der new jersey seite blockierten
einen angriff im stil des d day erwartet
ein entscheidender teil ist die
der kanal dort hat wasser des flusses
sachen gepackt und sind weggezogen
bewässerungskanäle terrassen und
wir wären wieder ein teil der großen
testen von torpedos ausgelegt
sachen zu packen und sich in ruhe ein
kriegsflotte noch stärker zu machen ich
blockiert hätte wäre das ein schwerer
hatten genug 1991 dank albaniens
betonklötze gleichen kleinen festungen
beobachtungstürme bilden die erste
nachwirkungen der stadien herrschaft
solartechnologie
sollten wir in den bunkern schutz suchen
die anlage stammt aus den späten 30er
die chinesin ji empfangen dann präsident
unter seiner herrschaft schließt
hatte
obstgärten zeigen dass die einwohner von
den eingang zur bucht
anlegestelle und noch wichtiger der
schlag gewesen
europäischen familie
erinnern an eine tödliche technologie
install geleitet und die obstgärten
die türme sollten den schützen beim
verteidigungslinie
abmildern
neues zuhause zu suchen
vom turm oben auf dem berg haben sie den
albanien ein bündnis mit der sowjetunion
sie sollte helfen feindliche
die wir vor vielen jahrhunderten
für hertha war das fahrrad am waren
abschnitt an
jahren nur wenige menschen wissen was
im falle eines nuklearen chemischen oder
nixon für roger war das ein zeichen dass
bewässert
haben sie an etwas geheimen gearbeitet
asco das beste aus der situation gemacht
teiler 3 blatt kennt den ort bis ins
1938 errichtet das us-militär erste
in den 70ern ist die albanische
von hier haben sie nach hereinkommenden
zielen helfen
kurs der torpedos verfolgt
anzahl und position lassen darauf
verloren haben
kriegsschiffe präzise zu lokalisieren es
stand gebracht
das wasser spielt hier eine wichtige
sie gaben einen probeschuss ab und die
etwas gefährlichem diese gebäude
etwas stimmt nicht mit diesem ort der
haben alles dreht sich um die
hier passiert ist
sie keine eingefleischten kommunisten
biologischen angriff sollten sie hier
bevölkerung in ständiger
kommunistischen ideale rogers feindes
angeboten ausschau gehalten
clemente ist gerade zehn jahre alt als
detail
geschütz stellungen auf dem 2000 hektar
dann hat es sie in den ruin getrieben
rolle allerdings nicht für schiffe
schließen dass ein großer teil der
alarmbereitschaft im fall eines angriffs
erzählen geschichten
mehr waren 1976 stirbt chinas herrscher
jungs auf dem turm sagten zwei grad
landwirtschaft die menschen lebten von
sie konnten eine 50 oder alle 455 minen
bevölkerung sie zur verteidigung nutzen
vollkommen sicher sein das projekt ist
ihre funktion wurde lange zeit geheim
von den plattformen aus haben die marine
sondern für waffen
großen gelände ein jahr später bricht
das friedliche bauern leben ein ende
rechts oder zwei grad links
sollte
seltsame verlassene bauwerke bedecken
von diesen turm aus haben sie ausschau
gehalten ein team von historikern unter
findet das wasser das dem dorf wohlstand
offiziere die bahn der torpedos
in der bucht von dell war auch einmal
die japaner haben hier ihre neuen toplos
der zweite weltkrieg aus platz rannte
ein ganzes land
nach großen kriegsschiffen gehalten wie
beobachtet und eine gute geschwindigkeit
zünden
einige von ihnen sind größer mit mehr
an der amerikanischen ostküste in
dieser turm ist einer von 15 sie sollten
der bismarck und der tipp zu baubeginn
getestet dies ist das torpedo
und richtung aufgeschrieben
mit den ferngesteuerten minen sind
es scheint als wäre das ganze land mit
räumen und mehr kampfausrüstung
delaware legen wanderdünen bedrohliche
helfen feindliche schiffe anzuvisieren
es muss ein system geben das alle
diesen merkwürdigen kuppeln überzogen
versorgungsschiffe die die bucht
baten frei die ostküste der usa ist
sie hatten auch beobachtungsposten
passieren endlich geschützt am 14 mai
auf straßen und plätzen in privatgärten
miteinander verbindet eine post
aufboten das war nicht ungefährlich
schließlich konnten sich torpedos auch
vor wem oder was sollten sie schützen
mal verlieren
in diesem test stationen haben sie die
komplette technologie auf dem prüfstand
gestellt verschiedene zünder
verschiedene wassertiefen sie haben
getestet ob die torpedos erst beim
aufprall oder schon in der nähe des
schiffs explodiert mich in den 1930
[Musik]